جواد العلي فنان سعودي كان لسنوات نشط جدا
وصاحب اغاني ضاربه وحفلات وغيرها واليوم
سيره جواد العلي مليت تويتر والسبب هذا
المقطع
نفسي دائما
نحاول انتبه ما يخوننا التعبير عرفت شلون
يعني انتبه يعني مو معقوله فنان طالع يبغى
او مذيع او
ممثل تيجي تقول له
يعني عيب انت سالت نفسك السلام عليكم يا
مرحبا يا اخي ما تبغى التابعه مثلا يعني
ابو نوره طالع في الحفله تيجي تقعد تقول
يا الله خلاص خلوه يعتزل عيب يعني انا
مرات تضايق يعني
كيف هذا رضا انه يقول هالكلمه
او فهمته يعني ما ابغى احنا نعطي مثال انا
اتكلم عن الجميع
مثل ما سمعنا جواد العلي في بث على التيك
توك قدم نصيحه للناس اللي بتقابلوا غيره
من النجوم وبتقول لهم كلام مؤذي من وجهه
نظره وحتى للي بيكتبوا هذا الكلام المقطع
انتشر طبعا بشكل كبير ومن بعد ما نفتح
نقاش واسع وتعليقات كثير ناس ايدوا كلامه
واكد عليك كمان وقالوا يعني فعلا عيب هذا
اللي بينقال لكن في ناس ثانيه كمان قالت
وين الغلط في اللي قال هو كان يغني زمان
وما فيش اي يزعل لانه الناس تقول يقعد
ولسه عايش شو شايفين الموضوع عادي
[موسيقى]